do you guys remember wework
a few years ago the company became
extremely popular amongst the startup
world for renting out office space
this popularity was accelerated by
softbank investing 10.65 billion into
the company in hopes of it going public
at 47 billion
but all these hopes and dreams were
crushed when it came out that instead of
investing this money effectively the ceo
adam newman was burning a significant
amount of it living it up
everything from smoking weed on private
jets to purchasing deck a million
mansions left and right it seems like
adam was under the impression that he
had already made it but his facade would
come crumbling down when wework fired
him in late 2019. this was followed up
by investors pulling out as much money
as they could and writing off the rest
as losses softbank for example wrote
down 9.2 billion dollars in losses in
regards to wework wework did eventually
go public but their market cap today has
come in at a much more modest 3.76
billion dollars which is over 90 lower
than their 47 billion valuation
after such a nightmare with wework you
would think that adam newman was done
for as his reputation was toast but
somehow in late 2021 adam regained his
position as a billionaire so here's the
rise and fall of wework and the
unexpected comeback of adam newman
taking a look back the story of adam
newman dates back to april 25th 1979 to
israel
adam didn't grow up with private jets
and mansions but his family was pretty
well off his father was a physician and
his mother was working towards becoming
a physician herself
this was actually the reason that the
family would move to the u.s when adam
was seven years old his mother needed to
complete her medical residency and what
better place to do that than the us the
us wasn't very kind to adam though as he
had a very tough time in school due to
his dyslexia he couldn't read or write
till third grade and even then these
tasks were a big struggle for adam
fortunately after four years in the u.s
adam's mother completed her residency
and the family would move back to israel
which gave adam a sense of familiarity
nonetheless his academic performance
didn't improve all that much so after
high school adam would go ahead and join
the israeli naval academy he would
follow up this training with five years
in the israeli navy between 1996 and
2001 and he was honorably discharged as
a captain unsure of what to do next adam
would move to new york city to live with
the sister who had built up a career
there as a model around the same time
adam would enroll in ziklin business
school and attempt to secure a business
degree but this was by no means his
focus it seems like what adam really
wanted to do was pursue entrepreneurship
in college he entered an
entrepreneurship competition and
submitted a project related to community
living but this wasn't very successful
as his idea wouldn't even pass the first
round of eliminations with no luck at
business competitions adam decided to go
ahead and try his luck at a real
business but this wasn't any better in
fact it was a lot worse given that he
was losing himself and his investors
money first he started a woman's
footwear brand and when that didn't pick
up any steam he switched over to selling
baby clothing starting up brands
including egg baby and crawlers as you
would guess these weren't very
successful endeavors either and adam's
expenses far outpaces revenue at one
point he was pulling in 2 million
revenue but spending 3 million dollars
despite the bleak outlook of his brands
adam decided to go all in on business
and dropped out of college with just 4
credits left he rented a small warehouse
in dumbo brooklyn which he converted
into a small office the office didn't
really help the financial situation of
the business but i think it helped them
feel better about the business
unfortunately though none of these
businesses would ever take off and adam
would eventually close all of them while
adam wasn't able to start up a
successful business one thing he was
extremely good at was making connections
and raising money and with his next
venture he would leverage his skill to
the max
the idea of we work actually dates back
to adam's days in the small warehouse
given the small nature of his business
he didn't have many employees and most
of the cubicles within his warehouse
were empty so adam reached out to his
landlord and asked them if he could sub
these parts of the warehouse his
landlord would agree and adam would
begin looking for potential tenants
this actually turned into a full-on
endeavor called green desk in 2008 which
adam ran with a friend named miguel
mckelvey adam and miguel were both big
fans of the shared office space idea
adam says that it reminded him of the
israeli community that he often missed
anyway greendesk would grow quite
substantially in the late 2000s and soon
enough adam was renting out over 100
office spaces for
to 2400 per month
despite this success in 2009 adam and
miguel would decide to sell the business
to their landlord and to cash out this
didn't mean that adam was done with the
shared office space business though
rather he just wanted a clean slate to
start something much bigger
in 2010 adam and miguel began looking
for larger and better locations that he
could rent out and this is when he would
run into a real estate developer named
joel scriber joella really liked the
office space sharing idea and offered to
become an angel investor in the company
he didn't just offer a few hundred
thousand or even a few million though he
offered to invest 15 million dollars
into the company in exchange for 33
stake
personally i have no clue why joel
decided to invest 15 million into a
company with no revenue it's also
unclear why he decided to invest his
money into two random dudes he just met
instead of just trying the business
himself
nonetheless that's what he decided to do
and that's how wework was born over the
next few years adam and miguel secured a
bunch of high appeal locations all
across new york this included a location
in new york soho district a location
near the empire state building and a
location in the meatpacking district
they would follow up with this expansion
across new york with national and even
international expansion in 2011 they
opened up a location in san francisco
and in 2012 they opened up a location in
tel aviv israel to adam it seemed like
he had finally hit the jackpot but this
wasn't exactly true
despite the fast expansion both adam and
miguel were well aware that anybody with
capital could just do what they were
doing at the end of the day they were
just leasing commercial buildings
breaking them up and then subleasing the
broken parts so the duo decided to add
elements that made them a bit unique
they installed beer pubs into their
buildings they put similar clients on
the same floor and they started a web
service called we connect that allowed
their clients to trade services all of
these small additions gave wework an
edge over the competition and soon
enough they're attracting billions of
dollars by 2014 wework was able to get
some of the most notable companies in
the world to invest in them this
included jpmorgan chase goldman sachs
harvard corporation wellington
management and a few others with all
this backing wework was able to raise
hundreds of millions of dollars with
each funding round and add dozens of
locations over the next few years in
2016 fortune magazine would choose
wework to be one of their top three
unicorns to bet on around the same time
softbank would launch their vision fund
and one of their top picks would of
course be wework very quickly softbank
would become wework's biggest backer
pouring in 18.5 billion dollars by the
end of 2019
it seemed like nothing could go wrong
wework had hundreds of locations around
the world and they basically had
unlimited funding but really it wasn't
all that great first of all the company
wasn't even close to being profitable
you see subleasing corporate space isn't
very lucrative as it has extremely high
overhead the company was burning
hundreds of millions every quarter and
there was still a long road to
profitability so there was no way wework
could survive without investors
considering this you would think that
adam would suck up to investors and try
his hardest to become independent from
them but it looks like adam actually had
no problem with relying on investors
maybe to him it seemed like an unlimited
source of cash but the thing he forgot
about was that all the investors were in
it for profit and sooner or later
they're gonna want returns initially
though they gave adam a considerable
amount of freedom and they didn't feel
the need to micromanage him this freedom
however got to adam's head and it wasn't
long until he was burning millions
one of adam's most notorious indulgences
was weedfield flight trips apparently
his friends and he smoked so much on
board that their crew had to wear oxygen
masks in one trip adam's private jet
wasn't available so he borrowed a 650 er
from gulf stream to go on a trip to
israel as you would guess he smoked on
the entire trip there and he left a
large amount of it in a cereal box for
the trip back when the crew found the
cereal box they weren't very happy you
see it smoking on board was one thing
transporting the substance
internationally was something else for
obvious reasons the crew nor gulfstream
wanted to be involved in this so they
reported adam and flew back to the us
without him during another trip to
mexico city it was reported that adam
and his colleagues were spitting vodka
on each other and they threw up all over
the cabin and after all that they didn't
even have the decency to tip their crew
adam quickly built up a reputation as
being a nightmare client amongst private
pilots and flight attendants but this
negative reputation wasn't just limited
to flights adam also had a reputation
for mistreating employees and other
executives he didn't necessarily
overwork them or abuse them per se but
he had very little respect for their
time
for example he often showed up hours
late to meetings if he showed up at all
all of this was already quite a bad
image but the final straw was that
wework wasn't just losing money it was
losing ludicrous amounts of money in
2018 for example they brought in 1.8
billion dollars and lost 1.6 billion
dollars at that point they were
basically paying two dollars for every
dollar they brought in
this business wasn't any better than
adam's original baby clothing business
but this time he was playing with
billions instead of millions
seeing this investors finally decided to
pull the plug on wework and the frat boy
that was running it softbank and the
rest of the board turned on adam and
forced him to take a 500 million buyout
personally i don't think adam deserved
anything given a terrible performance
but technically this was a lot less than
the 14 billion dollars adam stake was
worth at the peak after everything was
said and done adam was left with
somewhere between 450 million and 750
million dollars in the meantime his
investors took losses in the tens of
billions and 2400 wework employees lost
their jobs
usually it's the everyday employee who
gets screwed while investors make bank
but in this case everyone got screwed
except adam
given adam's infamous history with we
work it's gonna be difficult for him to
start a new company and raise money but
this doesn't really matter for him given
that he already has plenty of money
even though he was publicly kicked out
and humiliated he did walk away with
roughly half a billion dollars and with
that sort of money all he had to do was
make some safe investments and cruise
back to billionaire status and that's
exactly what he did
ever since the wework i was staying at
adam has mostly avoided the spotlight
but recently he did agree to do an
interview after regaining billionaire
status in the interview he was actually
given a bunch of tough questions but
adam was extremely well prepared for the
interview and handled it really well
given the circumstances many have gone
on to call adam a genius for making a
billion dollars while his company didn't
even make a penny others think that adam
is a snake or salesman that manipulated
his way to the top either way though it
doesn't really look like adam cares
and i think this statement from adam
sums up his thoughts pretty well
adam has some regrets but no apologies
would you guys do what adam did if it
meant becoming a billionaire comment
that down below
also drop a like if you wish you had
some of adam's investors by your side
and of course consider checking out our
international channels to watch our
videos in other languages and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one
[Music]